hello and welcome to this video playing
I am light like let's do this it's
Martin son xander is at a German I am ok
probably Queens gambit here let's see
what is playing the classical one ce
primary night BTW 7 and no he goes for
c5 yeah one of the lines way I
definitely have to have to be a brush up
my repertoire because what I'm playing
there it's not so testing as I've
learned in the last couple of years it's
not I mean it's interesting that line
still but it's something that I should
yeah I proved my knowledge on ok that
HCG form is some the way it is normally
played gaining space on the King side
and trying to shut out that bishop on
g61 ideas night 2d to Bishop d3 f4
pushing the whole King side forward ok
that's interesting f6 it's preparing 95
I guess hmm yeah definitely an option
maybe drop this back hey Scott bishop c7
now or I don't like my position I really
have to look at that line ok didn't play
Bishop see sound and scripts now I get
an F for k it's got night a five who is
that dangerous Jim my beam but I have to
get something going here it was the
whole point yeah it's also got night see
for this is Sir what is really looking
annoying not just an something to be
three okay let's put the CM now night
see for possibly 93 looks dangerous
hmm yeah what to do against this thing
yeah you should have to we might just
take on a five I don't know they have to
have to get rid of that night I cannot
let it stay there
it takes f5 I mean GTX that's probably
not so bad
and I wonder if he can make a sacrifice
all of it just let me take only 3 Jim
yeah I've seen this idea but I wasn't
sure if it if it's any good there so TX
ok I'm going to take this take take
first thing later on yeah I mean okay
yes to take with the night and now look
T 1 d4 is so this week now it's probably
excellent for me i don't i don't see
here i don't see any any black
compensation for the pawn and I've ever
been that ok plates this interesting
move going form up for him ok greene
takes a snide six and Bishop takes rook
takes the night is hanging first so he
cannot oops he thinks he can I can take
f2 ah ok ok ok that was a stupid blunder
out of a pretty good position actually
and shoot and he's got Quincy three
other sets the worst
it was bad that position was was pretty
good for white very sure about it I came
maybe this move I don't know it takes
twice on f2 then be too and I've worked
his seven that should be ok he looked
his seven as an ID anyway yeah problem
was I couldn't move the night anywhere
else 96 there was PG 3 check it's very
embarrassing
yeah strong movements playing as well so
what happens here I can play 97 and grab
but he's got Knight f3 himself
shoot and
can take a look-see to a rookie to check
check now i'm ok let all this cost time
that did cross time time morning check
I am slightly slightly down on time 43
seconds and i'm not done more time
actually that's good I was thinking I
was but the position isn't any good
trying 495 and to grabbing the shiny
it's difficult difficult to avoid to
draw here ok that's surprising check
check check
that looks pretty good actually like
this
97 how do i promote that I've got no
time here shoot maybe this to bring this
around check and stop use the night to
stop this I don't believe the [ __ ] for
I'm for betting on time this is crazy
this is crazy I didn't look at the clock
at all this is the biggest joke ever I'm
just waiting here and I didn't look at
the clock three-year just 95 is winning
this is a draw I don't know ah I
probably I shouldn't play earlier in the
day it's not a good idea anyway yeah the
worst part is that actually any of this
happened because this position here is
just good for white I think that Queen
c7 is actually still okay for him it's
really okay hmm funny yeah I didn't see
that Queen g3 business I was obviously
banking on Jace but quite embarrassing
so well here King up to g2 and the
engine believes look f1 is good for me
but this is a tough move to play now
engine gives a win Neff actually the
thing is that just looks super scary but
there is no made or anything check check
now i can understand i mean then this is
very strong I'm threatening Bishop b6
and yeah
something like this I mean I'm also
having this check yes I related to that
each attending kind of here yes what
happened later here okay now can it was
pretty much on no time no g5 seems to
win for black don't quite get why to be
honest why is that not working I a for
just hangs at the lemons what's wrong
check I like that ending was probably
full of mistakes by by both players
check I think him playing into that is
also very questionable chan the other
ending is winning for what check and I
had like 15 more minutes seconds it's
crazy that I'm not winning this it's
really crazy yeah and this is exactly
how it has to be played I played that
right just have to play 95 check check
and promote I mean this is easiest ever
took me so long that I actually got that
low that night see form of him yeah i
was thinking about this but does this
wasn't this wasn't good yeah i mean here
i'm i'm losing yeah i still have to be
quicker now if I've is kind of clear
check crazy sometimes habit and I said
early in the morning Gap you should play
chess probably okay anyway I hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching